hello i'm greg gutfeld with katie
pavlich geraldo rivera jesse water since
you won a gold medal for doing a floor
exercise on the gold medal
dana breno the five
[Music]
you never know when you really need a
dose of patriotism until you get it into
your system
and then it's like wow that felt pretty
awesome we're referring to an american
olympian getting a ton of attention for
all the right reasons
tamara mensa stock making history in
tokyo after becoming the first black
american woman to take home a gold medal
in wrestling
but unlike some other athletes who have
used their platforms to protest and
criticize america
she has no problem praising our country
tamara is saying quote
i love representing the u.s i freaking
love living there
i love it and i'm so happy i get to
represent
usa she then went on to give this
emotional response at a press conference
i'm feeling very happy and i keep trying
not to cry but it keeps happening
what does this mean for the popularity
of the sport and for all the young girls
out there that are going to see you and
feel inspiration
it means that they see someone like
themselves
on that podium just because you're a
female it doesn't mean you can't
accomplish
the biggest of goals and being an
olympic champ
is one of the hardest things i have ever
done in my entire life and i can say
it's well worth it
so obviously the sheer positivity coming
from that young woman
is welcome relief and we all know it's
that attitude that will carry her
throughout life
people might mock the power of positive
thinking but i dare you to find a
failure among anyone who employs it
obstacles become adventures and setbacks
become challenges
contrast that with the activist persona
which dictates any expression of glee or
gratitude
is viewed as counter to their mission
everything must be part of the great
struggle
against perceived depression caused by
the evil country you represent
but last night this great athlete
reminded everyone why the olympics is so
special
it should be the greatest time of your
life for you and your country
and i'm saying that as someone who hates
the olympics
i'll just stare so katie now that's like
old school
olympics like you remember growing up
happy happy athletes happy winners
patriotism everybody's adorable
i just love the wholesome goodness and
gratitude that she showed
to her coaches to her own hard work and
her work ethic
to her ability to take on challenges and
overcome them i feel like we live in a
time now where people think taking away
challenges is beneficial to people when
really
challenges allow us to overcome
adversity and achieve great things
i love that she's a small town gal from
texas and her dad
is an immigrant from ghana who came here
somewhat recently
and believed in the dream of america for
himself and for his family
and to watch his daughter take home a
gold medal to represent the united
states of america
is amazing and i think it is what
everybody really needed
and i just love everything about her and
i hope that she gets to go back again
this was her first olympics also
impressive to go in and win gold the
first time
so congratulations to her and thank you
for giving us all
some optimism and grabbing something fun
to talk about jessie isn't it
does it strike you with sad that she has
accomplished more in her short life so
far than you will
in your entire life she doesn't have a
number one best seller that's just what
i wanted to do she will
she will maybe she will
and i heard she might be doing a little
fox on a few days i can't wait for that
interview
i'm excited tomorrow morning she's going
to be on with me in
america's newsroom tomorrow uh that'll
be one o'clock oh there it is
tokyo but we're so excited to have her
for sure i'll be watching that
because she is just brimming with
exuberance and it's contagious
for anybody that watches that and what
i've noticed that the people that are
happy are also patriotic it takes
happiness to be patriotic because
happiness a key component according to
moi
yes is that's french grateful
yes and when you're grateful you're
living in the moment and you appreciate
the blessings of everything around you
and there's nowhere where the blessings
are as plentiful
as the united states of america so
people that are grateful
express that and that's inspiring to
other people
who are watching at home we don't want
to feel guilty when we watch the
olympics we could just watch cnn if we
wanted to feel that way
did you notice how this story a black
female gold medal winning wrestler
hasn't been covered on cnn and msnbc
or cbs now why do you think that is she
checks all the boxes
black she's female gold medal winner one
box she doesn't check
she's not patriotic so they can't put
that
story on because that story doesn't jive
i mean on patreon
she is patriotic right they sell the
story of black athletes who are
unpatriotic they sell stories of black
athletes that
maybe didn't pass a drug test this story
is not that this is all beautiful
all patriotic and they're not sharing
that with the audience
and that's something to think about and
why hasn't joe biden
been saying anything about the olympics
why is that what
if president trump were president right
now he would be tweeting
he would be galvanizing us to watch it
would be unifying he'd be like
you know on twitter big win for the
female rowers in tokyo
the precision and beauty and power that
they dip those oars into the water
they will have a big celebration back at
the white house with the also
beautiful first lady melania go usa
he would know the battle cap for sure he
would know the medal count
that was almost verbatim of what he
would what were you writing them for him
yeah
i was deeply impressed herald doesn't it
kind she reminds me of uh mary lou
retton remember her
sure perfect 10. you know can i just
speak more broadly rather than
referencing mary lou
retton who was a great champion how dare
you i
am a old-fashioned patriot and i think
that you and katie
both made a very eloquent presentation
in that regard
i also believe her in the first
amendment i think that people have the
right to
protest they can use any platform that
they have access to
they can you know they have total
freedom of speech but i
as an old-fashioned person you can tell
by my mullet
uh i i i really feel that the olympics
as not the appropriate stage to be
negative about your country the reason i
love the olympics one of the reasons
aside from the superb
athleticism is that it's the
old-fashioned patriot here's the flag of
this mexico and
you know i you know the uh the pick a
country france and this and africa and
where's that country
uh could deserve and all this uh i mean
ivory coast however you say it
but i i think that using the olympics as
a stage to make a
political point is a cheap shot and i
i really believe that for instance the
women's soccer team and how they started
their run
there were so many americans that i knew
were cheering sweden
in the three-zip route of the american
soccer i know that's very controversial
statement
and i apologize if i offend you but i
detest people grabbing the opportunism
of that stage and cheapening it i i
don't even like the kneeling in the
football games i also
thought that that knocked off the nfl
from its uh
from its its momentum it's a distraction
it'd be like us on the five all of a
sudden start throwing a football in the
middle of a political
discussion which i think we should do
some people used to i believe but anyway
so there's a few things um i think that
the adversity point is a really good one
and just to clarify so
her father actually died um in when she
was in high school right
and it was on her way his way he was on
his way back from one of her events
and she almost quit the sport altogether
but then
she said she was inspired to pick
herself back up she said she loves
getting beat up and she loves beating
people up
um but then she also talked about how
nervous she was she tells her coaches
i'm nervous i'm scared
i'm freaking out here help me out and so
somehow she's able to
take all of those nerves and all that
anxious energy and transform it into
something that is absolutely
incredible she knew how to bite the
metal she knew how to bite the metal um
the other thing is
she with her prize money she's going to
buy her mom her
mom's dream which is to have a food
truck yes i think she should call it
gold medal barbecue mode because
apparently greg it's barbecue that she's
especially well she's texas i mean it's
got to be barbecued right now what else
is it going to be
it's not going to be a sushi truck yeah
so but that
that would be my dream to own a barbecue
truck but i wouldn't have any customers
you wouldn't but she's going to have a
lot of customers and i'm sorry it's
going to be great to talk to her she was
she is fully her authentic self
and i think all of us could learn a lot
from that excellent well that was fun
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else